all right everybody I'm Laura Ingram
this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg
now they have tentatively agreed to
fight each other in the Vegas octagon
to quote Joe Biden no joke
so who better to handicap this fight
than MMA Legends Colby Covington and
Michael Chandler they're going to join
us in a bit later in the hour to weigh
in on the Battle Royale and I want to
get you involved too so go to my Twitter
at Ingram angle or Instagram at Ingram
radio and answer this poll question
who would win a cage match
Elon Musk or Mark Zuckerberg your
results later in the hour but First Sex
Lies and whistleblowers that's the focus
of tonight's angle
now just when you thought the bidens
couldn't get any sleazier they surprise
you
whether it's sniffing girls hair or cop
on a feel from Ava Longoria at the White
House the president has no shame or no
sense or maybe neither
now the same arrogance is seen in his
son and now we're discovering more Laura
details about hunter's leisure
activities the LA Times is reporting
that a founder of something called
sanctum a private sex club in Los
Angeles was banned from that club after
he had the nerve to name Hunter Biden as
a member
so what is exactly is this prestigious
Club
it was created in 2013 after the founder
watched the Tom Cruise movie Eyes Wide
Shut which features scenes in which
wealthy Elites gather at a secretive
orgy
and with a carefully curated guest list
and membership fees of up to 75 000 a
year it became the free love private
playground of Hollywood actors rock
stars Chief Executives City officials
and run-of-the-mill millionaires
so is it any surprise that an IRS
whistleblower named Gary shapely is
claiming that the hunter Biden case
codenamed Sportsman was opened in 2018
as an offshoot of an investigation into
some foreign based online porn platform
what a classy Bunch are these people
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
this same whistleblower says that it was
way back in November 2019 that the FBI
confirmed the authenticity of Hunter's
laptop by matching the device the number
on the device against Hunter Biden's
Apple iCloud ID
now remember that's nearly a year before
our corrupt CIA and FBI told social
media companies to censor coverage of
the laptop
so the feds knew it was his and yet went
public on the false grounds that this
whole thing with the laptop was somehow
engineered by Russia
well the truth is when Federal
investigators reviewed the laptop they
found real evidence of multiple felonies
these tax crimes cover an estimated
2.2 million in unreported tax on global
income streams to Mr Biden and his
associates from Ukraine Romania and
China totaling
17.3 million from 2014 to 2019.
yeah what's 17.3 million dollars among
friends and Associates just foreign
income a lot of it went to the bidens
documented on the laptop now no wonder
they didn't want it to see the light of
day
thus in early 2020
affidavits were drafted for search
warrant applications in three states in
Washington DC
The Whistleblower testified that in
addition to the warrants they had all
planned about 15 interviews
but after Biden became the presumptive
Democrat nominee career doj officials
shocking they swooped in and they
started dragging their feet on this IRS
request
and then just uh to close the Biden
protection Loop the doj ordered a cease
and desist on any overt investigation of
any influence peddling scheme involving
the bidens
again this was after they'd sat on the
evidence of Hunter's alleged criminal
wrongdoing for almost an entire year
this is a huge story
and only now are we discovering just how
Brazen the Biden demands for foreign
payouts actually were whistleblowers say
reoccurring unjustified delays pervaded
the investigation including an author
authenticating a WhatsApp message in
which Hunter Biden demands payment from
Chinese officials noting that his father
is in the room
I thought they never talked about
business
well in this encrypted message Hunter is
making these not so veiled threats
against Chinese businessman Henry Zhao
saying I'm sitting here with my father
and we would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
if I get a call or text from anyone
involved in this other than you Zhang or
the chairman
I'll make certain that between the man
sitting next to me and every person he
knows and my ability to forever hold a
grudge that you will regret not
following my directions like the mob
I'm sitting here waiting for a call with
my father
hmm
then my personal favorite of all these
messages where Hunter drops the stick
for the carrot saying
the bidens are the best at knowing and
doing exactly what the chairman wants
from this partnership please let's not
quibble over peanuts
notice he didn't say I he said the
bidens know exactly what the chairman
wants from this partnership
so it's pay to play it's obvious it's
influence pedaling 101. it's not about
any you know issue regarding drugs or
how many strippers Hunter could buy with
that pile of Chinese cash it's about
what Hunter likely promised them and I
don't know future trade or foreign
policy that really matters to the
Chinese
now we know why the feds were anxious to
trot out hunter's plea deal don't we
where he pled guilty at only two measly
misdemeanors even when the IRS was
recommending far more serious charges
nothing to look at here at all time to
move on right
urges Biden's allies which of course
includes the Press
he has this at least the criminal side
of it uh you know behind him that this
investigation is effectively over now
this is done this is over
this is wishful thinking
the scope and scale of this Scandal is
far more serious than Hunters hookers
and cocaine the real Scandal is number
one America at this moment could very
well have a compromised man leading our
armed forces and our domestic policy
number two just as important our FBI in
doj apparently conspired to hide that
information from the public
and the Democrats they love to prattle
on don't they about election
interference by Russia
what do you call what happened here
if you're the prosecutor on the hunter
Biden case
I live with yourself pushing that plea
deal
and if your judge Mary Mary Ellen
norelka presiding over this case how do
you not simply reject this plea deal
given the information that we just laid
out
we all know what would be happening if
these facts involved a Republican
president and his son
there'd be breathless wall-to-wall media
coverage calls for impeachment talk of
treason and demands for jail time
MSNBC and CNN that have special Graphics
packages all ready for the occasion
White House in crisis a time for
Reckoning
as things stand now Americans have
little reason to believe that our
president's foreign policy decisions
aren't tainted
we can all agree on one thing
China and Ukraine were not paying top
dollar for Hunter's brilliant business
expertise
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else